[Music]
if we're talking about free speech the
reason you need to study history I think
is to understand how fortunate we are to
have that right and in how many
different times and places it's been
contested and restricted and denied one
of the things you'll learn when you read
history is that actually the Vietnam War
was the first war that Americans had the
right to criticize and it became a
Supreme Court case called Cohen V
California and in Cohen V California a
guy walked into a draft board wearing a
jacket that said F the draft and he was
arrested and the only reason you can
walk around now wearing a jacket that
says F the draft or F the war in Iraq or
F the president is because of Cohen if
you don't know that history you don't
know how precious this freedom is no
freedom is absolute or should be right
you you you can't call the White House
and say you want to assassinate the
president right I'm a university
professor and I can't say to a student I
really like the sweater you're wearing
and if you wear it on Thursday I'll give
you an A all right I that's if you want
a restriction on my freedom by the way
it's one that I'm happy to abide by it's
just a gratuitous example of how there's
all sorts of speech that we do not allow
and should not allow but we also don't
have to reinvent the wheel there's a
hundred years of case law and
constitutional discussion about this
very question who should be able to talk
and when is their talk their speech so
intolerant and so awful that we can't
allow it
and so it seems to me the other thing
that we could be teaching in schools is
precisely that history that is the
history of the debate surrounding who
gets to talk so you know every American
should know about
for Wendell Holmes famous dictum freedom
of speech doesn't include shouting fire
in a crowded theater but they should
also know that in that case Oliver
Wendell Holmes actually upheld the
censorship of somebody that wanted to
distribute anti conscription anti draft
from leaflets because he said there was
a war going on the first world war and
he believed that distributing anti-draft
literature during a war was the
equivalent of shouting fire in a crowded
theater now the doctrine has evolved
since then right and now you know during
the Iraq and Afghanistan war you were
perfectly free to distribute pamphlets
saying you didn't think there should be
a draft so our standards of what's
acceptable and our standards of what
should be tolerated have changed over
time and I think everybody should know
about those changes I think that's part
of becoming a citizen I am a Liberal
Democrat in fact I'm almost a caricature
of a liberal democratic my father was in
the Peace Corps I was in the Peace Corps
I'm Jewish I have a PhD I'm like a
cartoon alright but part of my
liberalism is an absolute commitment to
free speech and one of the things I find
most upsetting boasted both at the
partisan anivia molecular level is the
way that free speed has now been cast
it's a kind of conservative value
I find this profoundly a historical
because all of the great warriors for
social justice in the past with names
like Frederick Douglass and WB Dubois
and Martin Luther King
they were absolutists on free speech
because they understood that it was the
people at the bottom that needed free
speech the most because it was all they
had so I had a really interesting
experience that for me kind of
crystallized this change and why it's so
important I've hosted Mary Beth tinker
in my class at Penn Mary Beth tinker was
in middle school when she and other
family members wore these
black armbands to school and Des Moines
to protest the Vietnam War they were
sent home from school and this
eventually became a very important test
case called Tinker v Des Moines
ultimately the Supreme Court in Tinker v
Des Moines upheld their right to do that
and it was in that case that justice
Fortas very famously wrote that students
and teachers don't shed their
constitutional rights at the schoolhouse
gate when meri good thinker is now a 65
year old person and she came to my class
to talk about this case and free speech
and the student said to her they said
listen miss tinker you were fighting the
good fight you were fighting the Vietnam
War Milo yeah innopolis and Ann Coulter
and Ben Shapiro they're not fighting the
good fight they're just hurting people
you know there are anti trans their
anti-gay they're anti black they are
just haters they injure people why
should they have the privilege of
speaking Mary Beth tinker wasn't having
it here's what he said he said listen in
the school that I attended in Des Moines
there were kids who had fathers and
brothers that were dying in Southeast
Asia do you think they weren't hurt by
this snot-nosed kid wearing this symbol
saying that their dad or brother was
dying for a lie you don't think that
hurt them wake up it hurt them speech
hurts but if that's gonna be your rubric
if that's gonna be your definition
forget my armband because I was hurting
people too
that's what speech does then they went
on to say well look this free speech
thing this is listen abstraction it's
not really about rights it's just about
power who has power who has the power to
talk she's not having that either she
says listen I was a 13 year old kid the
only power I had was my speech that was
it and speech over time
has been a weapon of the powerless if
you go ahead and censor it eventually
it's going to be turned against the
people with the least power and it may
be turned against you
[Music]